just a few minutes ago the grand opening
of the gateway district just a block
from the arts district three new
businesses have opened up their doors
and jeremy j ford is there joining us
from commerce and wyoming telling us why
businesses really want to be in this
area
the tappan ash social club spark design
group and the kiwi floor on design are
all open for business i caught up with
the owner of nikita design who tells me
exactly why she decided to open
in this area
randy garrett is the owner of nakiti
floral design she's been arranging
flowers for customers in a warehouse
setting for several years but decided it
was time to move into a storefront to
offer better face to face service a lot
of the businesses are finally realizing
the potential of being downtown
and
you know we're just trying to make it
cleaner safer for people to come down
here just like every other city
and it is thriving big time a lot of
people are taking those chances which is
great as for the other businesses
tapping ash is a speakeasy style cigar
lounge which features a fully stocked
humidor and self-serve tap system spark
design group is an architectural studio
earlier there was a ribbon cutting with
city council members and commissioners
welcoming the businesses to the area
from the gateway district jeremy j ford
live local now